here's a look at the most recent numbers
at ccsd more than 11 000 cases
districtwide recorded since last july
about
7 300 of those students another 3 800
make up the staff and central staff
classes on pause at the end of this week
amid the spread of covet at ccsd and
yesterday's abrupt announcement has many
parents on the hunt for someone to take
care of their children sally jaramillo
spoke to daycare centers and she joins
us live with what they're seeing sally
as you can imagine many parents feeling
frustrated and concerned come friday
schools will look like this
empty now some child care centers tell
me their phones can't stop ringing
daniel strong of strong family daycare
has been open for two years and says
she's never seen anything like this
phones ringing nonstop as parents try to
find care for their kids unfortunately
she can't take any new students i really
don't have any space
and then with us having so little
help
it's hard to find people to work for us
right now with so many people getting
sick strong says the school district
should have been more
prepared back out live another concern
for some parents has been food as many
kids get free breakfast and lunch at
school now project for humanity is
offering free meals to families as well
as ccsd and you can find that all that
information on our website eight newsnow
dot com for now reporting live sally
jaramillo live local now thank you very
much sally we just learned that they are
providing extra meals for kids to take
home tomorrow now we want to know are
you having to take off work during this
pause because your child won't be going
to school from friday to tuesday join
the conversation on our social media
we'll have the results coming up tonight
at 5